et toi là on est en pleine nuit ce mec
tu appelles tu fais soucht accélère le
pam et rattrape c'est à toi que je parle
à linky tout l'alcool regard perdu je la
vois arriver au ralenti la bonne vieille
patate de forain dans quelques instants
tu vas te l'apprendre en pleine face
c'est ta première fois ne t'inquiète pas
ça va bien se passer ou peut-être pas on
va expliquer avec la science que ça va
faire sur ton corps qu'est ce qu'on
ressent quand on est ko qu'est ce que tu
dois faire pour éviter de mourir d'un
coup de poing à paris une personne sur
sept va se faire agresser dans l'année
alors autant être bien renseigné
pourquoi un seul coupe de mettre ko dans
les films un combat de rue ça ressemble
à ça
dans la réalité non on s'épuise vite
c'est brouillon et un coup bien placé
même pas très puissant peut terminer le
combat mais comment ça c'est observons
ça ou ralenti sous le choc ta tête va
pivoter sauf ton cerveau qui flottait
tranquillement dans son liquide céphalo
rachidien et qui s'écrasent contre ton
crâne et c'est pas fini comme ta nuque
ne peut pas tourner à 360 degrés les
tendons vont l'arrêter brusquement coup
de frein nouveau choc ta tête tu es tu
un kinder et le cerveau la surprise le
problème c'est que tes pensées ta
conscience ce sont des neurones traversy
signaux électriques et là tout est
mélangé c'est l'orage dans ton crâne
comme pour un ordinateur un c'est
dangereux aussi étonnant que ça puisse
paraître la science ne sait pas
exactement où comment et pourquoi la
conscience et à compans que le chaos est
une protection du cerveau pour éviter
plus de dommages comme un redémarrage
après un bug on soupçonne aussi une
surcharge du noyau réticulaire
thalamique la zone qui gère le passage
de l'état d'éveil à celui de sommeil
fraude car où ça serait comme s'endormir
plus étonnant encore la perte de
conscience peut être incomplète des
régions du cerveau reste allumée pour
soeur à lisieux ouvert se remit
instinctivement de bombes sonné le
regard dans le vide il est ko mais il ne
le sait pas encore ça c'est très
dangereux tu es complètement vulnérable
à une patate de plein fouet sans
résistance musculaire qui pourrait te
faire sombrer direct dans le coma
récemment d'ailleurs un français à tuer
son adversaire avec un simple coup de
coude c'est pour ça que l'arbitré
vérifie que tu réagis encore avec une
petite pression sur le poids il veut
éviter la commotion cérébrale voire la
mort maintenant tu te pose souvent la
question y at il un moyen d'éviter
d'être ko certains boxeurs peuvent se
prendre d'énormes patate est resté
debout ouvrez donc habitués notre
cerveau à résister à ses coûts ça serait
juste une question de mental non c'est
de la technique tout simplement il faut
vite et que ta tête pivote on muscle le
coup comme un taureau on le verrouille
menton baisser pour former un bloc
inébranlable mais là tu es dans la rue
sans préparation alors que faire tu peux
limiter les risques en mettant les mains
devant toi c'est un message diplomatique
d'apaisement mais c'est surtout une
façon de limiter l'accès à ta tête
surtout si tu as les bras long mais
attention car il y assure ton corps un
deuxième moyen de mettre ko un organe
pourtant très éloignée du cerveau le
foie royal ce boxeur n'a aucun problème
encaissé plein de coups la tête mais à
quoi fois et boum dodo un fois tu l'as
déjà vu chez son boucher c'est mou très
mou puisque ses 73 % d'eau normalement
la cage thoracique est censé protéger ce
genre d'organes fragile et le foie lui
ben il dépasse un peu un simple coup à 5
mètres/seconde peu le déchirer or un
humain lambda frappe entre 6 et 7 mètres
seconde n'importe qui peut donc exploser
un fois all à la question vous poser
c'est pourquoi ça met ko ça n'a aucun
lien avec le cerveau non en fait un coup
au foie va déclencher une réaction
bizarre longue de choc va se propager de
l'organe jusqu'au système nerveux
autonome dans la colonne vertébrale des
nervis taux qui contrôlent ton rythme
cardiaque ou ta respiration c'est ça le
problème la décharge électrique du coup
vallée ralentir la pression sanguine va
chuter ton cerveau n'est plus assez et
reggae un peu comme sortir du lit trop
vite ta tête tourne tu vois flou
effondre si tu veux éviter de te
retrouver dans cette situation faut
savoir contre-attaqué alors allons voir
comment faire un coup de poing
surpuissant grâce à la science c'est pas
parce que tu as le corps d'une chips que
tu ne peux pas te battre tik tok un
bodybuilder n'a pas forcément les coups
les plus puissants qui entraîne surtout
des fibres lentes peu efficace pour les
mouvements explosif le secret d'un coup
puissant c'est surtout une question de
physique de conservation de l'énergie la
vitesse d'un coup est en moyenne de 25
km heure le poids de son bras 7 kg avec
ça on peut calculer l'énergie cinétique
ça nous donne une puissance de 15000
joule secondes ça paraît beaucoup mais
c'est deux fois moins qu'un penalty en
pleine tête un boxeur pro peut monter
jusqu'à 40 km heure avec des pics à 50
chez les combattants exceptionnel mais
pour augmenter l'énergie cinétique qui
la vitesse est bien mais le mieux c'est
encore d'ajouter de la masse le bras ne
suffit pas il faut mettre tout ton corps
dans le coup avec un simple pivot du
bassin est un pas en avant s'est pas 7
kilos que tu projettes c'est tout ton
poids on appelle ça la chaîne cinétique
quand tu prends fermement appuyé du pied
sur le sol l'énergie va remonter dans ta
jambe tu es en jetons torse et enfin
tombera chaque muscle va ajouter de
l'énergie dont les surpuissants muscles
fessiers et dorsaux tous concentrés dans
ton point au moment de l'impact pense a
expiré savard est justifiée la chaîne
cinétique qui va s'abattre d'un blog sur
ta cible c'est en exploitant cette
technique que bruce lee a fait entrer
dans la légende le warning punchs un
coup de poing avec quasiment pas d'élan
mais qui réussit c'est quand même
envoyer l'adversaire au tapis mais
attention à de tels niveaux de puissance
évident de frapper avec ton poings
fermés sans protection les os du crâne
sont tellement dur que tu risques de te
casser les phalanges tir de retrouver
avec des dents encastré dans le point et
là gros risque de vih non il vaut mieux
frapper la paume ouverte ce qu'on
appelle la pomme de l'ours et surtout tu
es obligé de viser la tête car il y a
les points faibles du corps humain dans
ken le survivant quelques doigts
enfoncés au bon endroit et c'est la mort
ces techniques qui existeraient
prétendument dans l'art au culte du dim
mak on dit même que bruce lee en a été
victime succombant plusieurs semaines
après un tel coup ces légendes ont-elles
un fond de vérité pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale le gouvernement japonais
a décidé de mener une enquête top
secrète réunir tous les jeux interdits
dans chaque dojo dans chaque école
d'arts martiaux on a demandé aux grands
maîtres d'expliquer leur technique
mortels tout a été compilée dans des
archives jamais retrouvé qui auraient dû
servir aux soldats se défendre contre
les américains bon ne nous mentons pas
tout ça a été un peu romancée par contre
on peut effectivement désactiver
certains organes avec un coup en
frappant dans le sternum par exemple la
zone et sans protection graisseuse et
musculaire
s'ils osent se brise tu performes boulot
plus simple le plexus solaire juste au
dessus d'une boule de nerfs ou connexion
profonde un coup puissant et tu vas sur
activer le système nerveux qui va se
faire contracter le diaphragme
paralysant momentanément la respiration
système nerveux n'a pas l'habitude
d'être autant stimulé ça va provoquer un
court-circuitage complet un chaos
neurovégétatif parfois une simple
pression doigt suffit en décalant le
nerf ici sous ton coup de cul peut
paralyser temporairement les
terminaisons nerveuses qui vont jusque
dans ton petit doigt il ya plusieurs
dizaines d'autres points faibles du
genre connu pour infliger d'affreuses
douleur ok ça marche dans les films
d'arts martiaux et dans le feu de
l'action dans la rue en matière de
bagarre tout le monde a un plan jusqu'à
ce qu'ils se prennent la première patate
c'est ce que le krav maga essayer de
résoudre avec des techniques instinctive
mordre la main frappé les doigts dans
les yeux patate dans la glotte cassage
de genoux avalanche de coups de coude on
dirait la description d'une bagarre de
cour de récré et c'est ce qui marche le
mieux en fait pour connaître les
meilleures techniques il suffit de
regarder celles qui sont interdites dans
les tournois sportifs et devinez quoi
tuer des gens avec une seule pression du
doigt comme dans le dim mak pas c'est
pas interdit c'est peut-être la
meilleure preuve que ça marche pas sinon
tous les combats devaient me ressemblera
à ça mais en attendant puisqu'on parle
de se défendre dans la rue protégez-vous
aussi sur internet avec north vpn vous
cliquez ici et vous fait croire à
internet que vous êtes connecté sur un
autre ordinateur à l'étranger ça a
quatre gros avantage déjà devenir
invisible sur internet comme un ninja
quasi impossible de vous tracer de vous
identifier ou d'utiliser vos données
personnelles deuxio vous protéger des
virus puisque tout est filtré avant
d'arriver sur votre ordinateur tertio
accéder à du contenu jugé ou bloqués en
france des sites qui vous interdisent
l'accès ou le catalogue netflix ou
disney plus différent selon les pays là
tout devient accessible enfin bénéficier
de prix plus avantageux à l'étranger par
exemple un billet d'avion une chambre
d'hôtel ou infra deuxième dans un jeu
vidéo si vous le prenez dans un pays
plus pauvres ou plus avantagés ça
coûtera moins cher des fois c'est moitié
prix et vu que 59 pays sont disponibles
chez north vpn il ya vraiment moyen
d'optimiser tout ça c'est compatible
absolument partout ordinateur téléphone
télé si ça vous fait peur sachez que
toutes vos données sont cryptées et
supprimer personne ne saura si vous
allez sur des sites louche et puis au
pire c'est si satisfait ou remboursé 30
jours pour tester si ça vous voulez pas
ça vous aura rien coûté chez science
trash on a un super cadeau pour vous
quatre mois gratuits sur chacune des
offres si vous n'avez jamais testé ce
vpn c'est l'occasion ultime de sauter le
pas le lien est dans la description
merci nord vpn quelle est la meilleure
technique de combat selon les
mathématiques des chercheurs ont analysé
des centaines de commandes free fight et
on a pu en extraire des statistiques
très précieuse par exemple quatre coups
sûrs cinq essaye de viser la tête c'est
ce qui va être principalement visés mais
75% des coûts n'arrive pas à destination
il faut frapper quatre fois la tête pour
espérer toucher contrairement au corps
ou 60% et frappe touche à pleine
puissance statistiquement c'est plus
facile d'infliger un ko au foie ou au
plexus qu'en pleine tête et tu peux
oublier tout ce qui coûte pied retourné
même si c'est impressionnant les
chiffres sont formels sarapp ce quasi
systématiquement en fait ce genre de
chaos et hyper art c'est juste que vous
voyez des compilations qu'il est sûre
représente maintenant allons au sol
quelle est la soumission la plus
efficace dans les faits il ya de grandes
chances qu'on ait s'est étranglé en
guillotine ou te faire une clé de bras
mais regarde plus de 90% de ces essais
sont infructueux
contrairement à l'étranglement par
derrière morales attaque le dos et
protège le tient bien d'autres
statistiques peuvent venir perturber
l'équilibré d'un combat celui qui se bat
à domicile un avantage la foule lui
étant favorable ce qui peut influencer
les arbitres rien que le fait d'être
gaucher augmente d'office de 14% son
hôte victoire tous ces avantages des
avantages ont été listés les maths sont
là comme une matrice invisible plaçant
un combattant favori avant même que le
premier coup ne soit portée enfin
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
la boxe un taux de mortalité plus élevé
que le mma etc octogone sanglant oui il
ya moins de règles les coûts sont plus
violents élégant quasi sans amorti mais
un combat de mma finit plus vite sans
que le combattant et a encaissé des
centaines de patates chez les boxeurs
les commotions s'accumulent et les
conséquences sur le long terme sont
parfois désastreuses on appelle ça la
démence du pugiliste ou le punch drunk
syndrome et oui le cerveau n'a pas de
récepteur à la douleur les boxeurs pros
ne peuvent pas sentir à quel point il
est endommagé et donc de risquer de se
lancer dans un nouveau combat avant que
ce soit réparé c'est pour ça qu'on leur
impose un repos de 28 jours quand ils
sont victime d'un ko ça explique des
règles bizarre comme quand il ya deux
médailles de bronze aux jo si la demi
finale s'est terminée par un ko
impossible de jouer la finale ton corps
a ses limites et justement comment
gagner un combat grâce à la chimie face
à une menace la peur accapare ton âme
hildahl la zone qui gère tes émotions
tout les hommes de la rationalité sont
ralenties tu passe en mode survie avec
trois réactions primitive combat la
fuite ou l'inhibition roi de paralyser
ou se mettre en boule la fuite est
toujours l'option la plus sèche mais à
ce moment il ya tellement de questions
dans ta tête tu es un peu perdu et la
vam décharge d'adrénaline ton coeur bat
très vite des poils se dressent pour
garder tes muscles bien au chaud des
vaisseaux sanguins se contracte pour les
techniques pures tu fasses perdu trop de
sang tu vas même peut-être turini dessus
pour évacuer du point inutile oui tu
deviens pâle des oreilles bourdonnent
est ta vision rétrécie mais pendant les
20 prochaines minutes des réflexes ont
décuplé ce n'est pas ton corps qui te
trahi en perdant ses moyens il essaie au
contraire de te donner des super
pouvoirs alors plutôt que se dire ok tu
entres paniquer mieux vaut l'accepter en
profiter des scientifiques ont mesuré la
force des coups d'un beau sûr dans son
état normal puis après s'être fait
gueule et dessus par son coach pour
provoquer une montée d'adrénaline
ça a suffit pour augmenter sa puissance
à 160% une autre hormone peut booster
les performances physiques la
testostérone et qu'on soit un homme ou
une femme il existe un moyen simple de
la faire augmenter une partie de jambes
en l'air à la veille d'un combat ça
pourrait augmenter tes performances de
130% ou pas en fait un et a eu plein
d'études scientifiques et là-dessus bain
tout le monde se contredit bon ça c'est
pour les moyens naturels non il existe
effectivement des substances pour
augmenter tes capacités de combat
il existe des pilules magiques que les
soldats nazis prenait avant les combats
ça les transformer en monstre de
puissance plus aucune fatigue plus
aucune douleur vigilance absolue
performances physiques augmenter et
sentiment d'invulnérabilité ces
comprimés c'était du pervitine on les
connaît aujourd'hui sous le nom de
méthamphétamine derrière le flacon y
avait quand même écrit seulement de
temps en temps mais forcément des
milliers de soldats sont devenus accros
les pressions hallucinations suicides
n'en prenez pas un nom vaut pas la peine
voilà maintenant vous savez comment vous
battre grâce à la science la prochaine
fois que vous voyez est signé avec ses
lunettes tout fin mai abonnés à science
trash fuyez c'est maintenant une machine
de guerre va
abonnez vous quand même à 6 ans trash
merci de nous avoir suivi sur cette
vidéo près dans ce que j'espère complète
merci à toi à l'écriture allez les amis
ciao
[Musique]